10 set for
and so this is the second part of my presentation
and as I said before it was jeans,
is it logical we talked about the myths associated
with the study of foreign languages
g hands up all those principles of blood
and now I want to tell you about the metho
s of learning languages and a  foul
other principles how to learn them so finally and
flash tool kit the
first most important question is can we
learn a foreign language as well as a
child masters the language now they are looking for
likes brushes and the first sentence are the
usual common ones we need
to learn the language just like a child learns it
give hold the way
it's called the natural way of
mastering ghede
and it's a fact that it's impossible to dispute
that children learn languages well in hong kong need
he people the sun people to all but t
e wrong conclusion that some peopl
can draw from this is i feel
ike i will sex it's such a principle if i
tart  learn a language like a child does,
then I will get a good
result lamia
100 songs  death in geralda conditions
in which his wife and I will start by saying
that the conditions in which children learn a
language and adults learn a language are different
conditions
one like a doll in fine
a second language
that affects their mastery of
this original first language
10 before they have no choice
and they have no other choice as she
said they need to learn a language from 30 and the
most important difference is when you
master your first native language
is the result of your life  life
process is not a conscious choice but
little and when you have no choice
yukin because usually when you have no choice
you cannot make the wrong
choice
ultimate tables and daikin another daikin
she is an adult she can really
make the wrong choices
choose inappropriate study methods for herself and as a
result quit  language learning did
not even come off the father he will give but this
does not mean at all that the children have mastered
speak your language faster and better ask them
apples
in English there is an expression when
we say that you are comparing apples and
oranges minsk
this means that you are comparing things
that are completely unrelated
for dolls
and this is the same case when we try to
compare how children learn the language and  how
an adult learns the language agulife
still pedan and dc in conditions it seems to me
that a fair comparison
can only be made in the same conditions of
college it is true that we adults
have some disadvantages but we
do not have some advantages that
children have
but we cannot say  that we are very much
losing to children looking which let's
see how children learn the language in what
conditions.
and first of all, children are in the family
as richard dance said and this means
that the child is surrounded by the language of the very
moment of his birth e
oxford soup and what does this mean it means that
in this there is the love of the mother of the father once a
flame
but also there is a game there is play time in
this  In the process, there is a natural
curiosity to learn about the world of place,
but in fact, these psychological
factors play a huge role in learning the
language n d b l potty and then we all go to
school and school will a safe on HIV or
contex formulas and at school we begin to
master a second language  already in a
formal environment and we communicate with
our classmates see enough more
for our mistakes the teacher corrects him you
sing when we speak and when we write
salsa dance show you and i
so language learning is also the result of
communication interaction with your
classmates and with other people
who  learn a foreign language
you love very much and also we all love to watch a
movie series listen to the radio even listen to  play
music
and spend and don't even pay attention to it
we
listen to the language
for a huge part of our lives anesthesia besides many friends ups
all this helps us to learn the language when
we are children fedya demos but if we count
new
and 365 days a year
lassa potentiates
and teaches  let's say we take the example of an 18
year old child in a for speed salon
so we multiply 306 5 by 18 years and plus by
24 hours because our brain learns the language
even when we sleep speaking and
raining as a result we get 78 thousand
eight hundred and forty hours of reading listening and
speaking
writing and living a language for a massage
i.e. language acquisition occurs as a
whole process and stretched over a
long period of time on the street
preservatives content such a doll is difficult
now let's look at the conditions in
which adults learn languages
of all we have the intervention of our n
tive language  there is an overlay or
interference
pronunciation of syntax and so
on besides,
children are actually more curious
than we are adults and still retain a share of the
curiosity of adult life, but not
like children
sing
100x and just like I said before,
adults may have a fear of speaking
fear of condemnation fear of committing  mistakes in
speech and fijaros they are afraid of condemnation of the
surrounding people like me in your los and
also of our life there are other factors we
have less time and at the moment suvan
and the son of chances from the regiment we are not in an
environment in which this
language learning constantly sounds
and does not  as a rule we are busy we have a
lot of other things we have work in general we have a
lot of other things in life